this is play for all game spots gaming
showcase for the summer
and charity efforts for ablegamers where
we talk about the latest
and greatest in video games and we're
talking about a game that has been out
for a while but
is not stopping in terms of dlc and
updates we're talking about
fallout 76 and here to talk about it
with me is jeff gardner project lead and
mark tucker the design director how are
you all doing today
wonderful how are you yeah we're all
we're all hanging in there so
i'm good uh and there's a lot of
exciting stuff going on fallout 76 so
i'm glad that you all can join me
uh to talk about steel rain that trailer
kind of has a lot of
implications for where fallout 76 is
gonna go so uh can you kind of give give
us a quick rundown of those who may have
missed it
yeah so uh still rain is the second half
of our brotherhood of steel uh story arc
so we
we kicked that off last year with steel
dawn we introduced a lot of new
characters
uh obviously the brotherhood of steel
had returned to appalachia
and you know over the course of that
story arc you you learn
that there's some conflict within the
leadership
of the brotherhood of steel and so as
you know
as a player uh you know engaging in
these quests you're gonna make some
interesting choices you're going to
learn a lot
about these leaders and the mission for
the brotherhood of steel
and by the end of steel dawn uh you know
things have really kind of come to a
head with that conflict but
you know uh trouble and you know
various events come in twos and threes
right so at the end of steel dawn
right when this conflict comes to a head
uh you're dealing with this other
conflict with
this super mutant attack and so that's
kind of where you leave off and steal
dawn and we pick up and steal rain
so now in steel rain you know yes you're
still dealing with the conflict within
within the leadership and trying to
decide
who you know who do you think is going
to forge the best path forward for the
brotherhood
but in addition to that you've got the
super mutant threat now that it has
emerged and
reports of missing people across across
appalachia so
that's kind of where we pick up that's
where um you know the player has to
take different quests or you're gonna
you're gonna be talking again with uh
dealing with raiders and uh the blue
ridge caravan
makes a fun appearance so there's you
know we're kind of tying back into a lot
of the existing
uh factions and npcs that we've
introduced uh
prior sort of the the evolution of
fallout 76 kind of going into a more uh
story-based kind of direction
i think was very exciting at first of
course uh things take time to kind of
flesh that out and it's
you're kind of starting to see the
fruits of that labor
um and it's it's very fascinating how
it's done for a live service game uh
obviously like mmorpgs have done this
for a while but how is the team handled
trying to tell stories within
a live service game like specifically
with steel rain how are you
able to handle factions and choice and
consequence in a persistent world
yeah you're right that's a really uh
tricky challenge in a multiplayer game
you know a lot of the choices we offer
players
we have to reflect those choices uh in
unique and different ways in
single-player games so we have to
leverage uh
well you know our instancing technology
where we can kind of reflect
the choices that they've made within
within these spaces inside the game
in the case of still rain choices you
made and still dawn
are going to affect your dialogue
choices and how
how these npcs interact with you
in steel rain and i will say like we
have some pretty meaningful
long lasting choices at the by the end
of this
uh content that really are going to sort
of determine
the future of the brotherhood in
appalachia now mark you said something
uh
very fascinating about you know the
having dire consequences
at the end of the steel reigns sort of
storyline now of course
i'm not going to ask you to give away
what happens um but
[Laughter]
uh but with that in mind um
does that present like new challenges
that you've hadn't had to face before in
terms of okay
where do we take the 76 story what's the
next story content gonna look like
or have you planned ahead for that and
accounted for
the sort of different directions like
all these players can make
there's a lot of planning that goes into
this uh you know we have a lot of unique
challenges with this
with this game because players can play
content in different orders
so we have to take that into account
when we're creating the content
we also have to deal with the reality
that our game is a prequel
and comes before all of the other
follow-up titles so that means anything
we create or add here
needs to fit within the greater fallout
universe
and and lore so those are challenges
right there that we have to contend with
and are always thinking about because we
can't
we have to be cognizant like if we add
something into this game and you know
it needs to stand up and fit within the
everything else that's that's come
before
and so that you know that right there is
a huge challenge being a prequel is
something that's
uh yeah i warn all of you
all for sure game developers don't do
prequels
back there so mark and i always have to
run our ideas past
who is the lead designer of fallout 3
and 4 and he's like our master now
um and it's it there's there's a lot of
implications there to everything we do
so
but it's fun it makes it makes it it's a
very interesting thing i'm not
complaining about it but at the same
time
you have creative restrictions there
that you don't otherwise
the the things that we want to do longer
term it's you know we have a lot of
ideas
and and things that we're thinking about
but um you know we're not
committed to any one thing just yet we
do listen to our players we
we like to hear what they say what they
think about the things we put in the
game
so that that kind of helps inform the
decisions we make longer term
yeah i actually have a question about
that a little later on but i guess i'll
ask it now since you brought it up
and i asked a lot of a lot i asked the
developers who do mmorpgs in ongoing
games about this like
how do you balance player feedback with
your vision for the game because i know
that
when fallout 76 kind of started there
was a very vocal community about the
direction
at launch and then kind of adjusted
course and now it's grown into something
that
you know maybe no one expected back when
it first launched so
how do you balance your vision with
player feedback and
um yeah how do you deal with that now
uh with the fallout 76 in the place that
it's in
there's you want to always read
and and try to look at player feedback
and try to take it from the point of
view
the fans just want what's best for the
game that they love right even if it's
negative
so you look at it and you take into
account and then hopefully mark and i
and others on this
project have a meta vision of the game
and we realize things both in terms of
what we can do
and what we can't do for different
reasons right there's always time
restraints
everything is sort of a priority weight
against something else
um a very interesting take on this is we
have found
one of the the things that we have done
in the last year is we've launched our
private
excuse me public test server on pc and
so we
really read and take that feedback very
seriously and mark can talk more details
about there's two systems we put in the
game
legendary perks and our our newest one
legendary crafting which
we have taken that feedback into account
and changed course heavily on what we
were trying to do
because all best all the best laid plans
like they don't
you think you're doing the right stuff
on paper or in a microcosm of the game
you're testing with 20 30 40 people when
it goes up to hundreds and thousands
things are
very different especially we test games
when you test a game like this in a very
isolated way you're testing a very
specific thing
where folks have played the game for
thousands and thousands of thousands or
see it very differently
like we've played it that way too but we
like we shortcut that content to see it
different so even pts
serve server feedback they've taken to
account low players aren't playing the
characters that they
they know this characters throw away so
are they playing it differently there's
all these sort of psychological things
but we really
that at the crux of it is we we take it
very seriously we read it all we try to
explain our reasoning
that was different for us too in the
past we sort of did things and we never
really explained folks why
and how but we took cues from other
games and services that do a better job
of going hey
we understand this isn't a popular
decision this is why we're doing it
and i find that works well in game
development and also with the community
at large as well so sometimes decisions
made are made for difficult reasons that
folks don't all understand but you try
to explain why
um now before we move on from steel rain
i do want to kind of ask a little bit
some uh specific things that you saw in
the trailer so
um there's two phrases uh choose justice
or choose unity
uh so i imagine that those themes kind
of represent the the choices you have to
make within the brotherhood
but also there's a power suit with uh
like this
red white and blue power suit like can
you tell me more about what what that's
about
about that all right go ahead that's all
you no we when they saw it there were
some people are like we
should they didn't like it and i was
like i'm sorry i love that
and then i'm opening the ruler design
director i was like i'm going to run
this by him i'm going to get a third
take on this
i love it put it in even more so um
anyways that's the funny anecdote on
that
yeah i don't think there's a specific
story behind that power armor in
relation to the story mark can talk more
about the story about the two miles yeah
the power armor in that case i think was
just something that looked really cool
and fit the moment
and it was exciting to look at plus the
contents
i don't know if this is a secret or not
but i guess someone can yell at me we
are launching this right after
uh fourth of july as well so the street
day right now it's july 7th
um now in terms of uh the themes as i
mentioned earlier the two the two
the two i guess split in the faction for
the brotherhood
uh can you tell me just at least a
little bit about like thematically what
you're going for in terms of
storytelling because i know
it could be kind of the brotherhood is
an iffy organization
as they've been recorded to fallout
since day one but
um you kind of like go back and forth
about how you feel especially throughout
all the different games that you played
throughout the series but um yeah what
kind of themes are you hitting here
when you're trying to tell this story
about a rift in the brotherhood of steel
well you know from the gecko we we
really wanted to try to
capture some of the the themes that
you've seen within the brotherhood
across the different
uh fallout games right and um we wanted
to capture that
uh and really kind of show the conflict
within uh
those themes right like the brotherhood
has done a lot of different things it's
there's a lot of different
offshoots and whatnot and so we wanted
to capture this
you know there was a sort of idealism uh
within the brotherhood originally where
sort of this
you know humanist organization where
there really are trying to help humanity
right but then there's sort of you could
with any idealism you can twist it
right things can change and you can kind
of make it into something different so
then you have this other version
that is still trying to help humanity
but in a much more
sort of uh hardliner
rigorous way and so we've kind of
reflected that with our two
uh two of our main characters we have um
paladin romani
uh and night shin and these are the two
folks that are
at odds with each other right like
paladin romani is really
more interested in directly helping
people
and and is not necessarily as concerned
with
you know keeping technology and hoarding
technology from everybody where like you
know shen
sees the dangers in technology and and
you know
shin also sees the dangers of you know
acting what he
the way he feels like romania is like
irrationally and we touch a lot of that
within our story arc so we have these
kind of two different ideals
uh coming to had and because they're so
isolated and they're far from
uh you know the the west coast the
headquarters the leadership of the
brotherhood
and they they've lost communication
they're kind of on an island and now
they're sort of
having to compete with each other for
who's whose ideals are going to take
uh take the lead and that's where you
know a lot of the player choice and
agency comes in
right and and so by the end that that'll
be heavily reflected in what the players
get to do
uh by the end of the the steel rain
quest line try not to spoil too much
yeah yeah oh man now the
the other thing i think that folks are
curious about is the
pit now i know that y'all don't have too
much to say on it quite yet
uh it is ways out but it is part of
fallout 76's effort to
what are called expeditions which are
venturing outside of
what we know as the fallout 76 uh
virginal map
and that seems to be really genuinely
exciting stuff
um and i feel like y'all can do a lot of
experimentation
with uh with where where fallout 76 goes
so uh am i on the mark there in terms of
like
expeditions are kind of your way to be
experimental i know there's not much to
share
but um yeah tell me a little bit about
more what you all are trying to do with
these
we you always want to go off map right
especially after a game has been out for
two
at this point it'll be two three years
folks have explored the map thoroughly
we can do different things with biomes
and creatures and
sunsets and skylines so there's and then
when mark and the folks in austin came
with a list of
places to go trust me there are a lot of
new places too
um but the pit seemed like an obvious
choice
um i was lucky enough i i worked i was a
lead producer on the original the pit
a long time ago that ages me quite a bit
so i
had nostalgia and i think todd howard
had nostalgia and we just wanted to do
it like
i love pittsburgh as a city it's near us
it's one of my favorite places to go
visit with my wife on long weekends and
stuff so we just really wanted to do it
and
we're super excited to be able to go
back there and expeditions are are a
neat way for that team to come up with
to gamify the
gamified a little more into and to open
up the idea that there are more
to come yeah i mean at a high level the
way we
we think about them and talk about them
uh internally
is you know just sort of our tagline is
like you know expeditions
are repeatable and randomized off-site
missions
to various exciting locales on the
fallout universe and
coupled with that you know there's we
have a strong story behind it
right we have a lot of a lot of
story-driven uh elements behind it so
um so yeah it's they're it's
it's fun because we're offering glimpses
into different parts of the fallout
universe
at this point in the timeline so you
know
we're going to the pit but it's actually
before
the fallout 3 dlc right so that's kind
of interesting we're going to get to
see sort of where things were at that
point in the timeline and we get to do
that with
other areas within the following
universe and some of the locations we
may end up going to
might be sort of smaller locations that
may never
make it into a real game so it's kind of
a fun opportunity as a fan
to see sort of these small windows
within the fallout universe that you
wouldn't
probably ever get to see otherwise i
can't wait to go back to vegas
new vegas fans out there know the vibes
but um
yeah fans as well yeah oh man but uh
yeah before we close this out i want to
give you all an opportunity is there
anything else that you want to share
about fallout 76
uh before we let you all go um just
quickly from me
remember it it's this probably been a
great labor of love and i just always
want to thank the fans and the folks
working on it
for for sticking with us and and seeing
this through
it's one of the most uh play games on
game pass right now
um you know it's it's been a sort of a
small renaissance and we like to do
experimental things with our patches we
haven't we haven't really had a cadence
of
this release on these dates or anything
so we just we like trying different
things and seeing what works and
and that is largely driven by the fans
uh both internally the in the dev studio
and externally on the forums and twitter
and reddit and discord now
um you know and again like this update's
free all the things we're talking about
are free so if you own the game and you
haven't turned it on in a long time
please come back
if you haven't you know check it out
it's um
it's a great place it's got an
unbelievable community of very welcoming
players who will
who will draw you in and it allows you
to create your own story in this
universe in a way that i think is unique
to a lot of games so i'm
i just i couldn't it's been a great joy
of my career and worked on this game for
the last several years so
thank you that's cool yeah that's cool
to hear mark got anything
uh yeah you know uh for those players
that uh
got the game when we first released and
haven't uh been back
you know we've been busy the last couple
years so i encourage you to come back
and see all the things we've added and
changed
it's a pretty different game from when
we launched and uh we're still adding a
lot of cool new stuff
you know we've been talking a lot about
steel rain today uh other things that
we've got in that update
uh we have a whole new season coming out
which is gonna be super awesome
uh featuring uh katie inkwell which we
introduced in a previous season
really fun stuff there uh and we touch a
little bit on legendary crafting that's
a whole new expansion
to our legendary item game we're also
adding in
a power armor legendary power armor
in this update which is going to be
really exciting and we have a new vendor
that's going to show up periodically in
the world
that's going to offer great deals with
our gold bullion currency so
there's a lot of cool stuff coming out
uh i really appreciate the fans that
have stuck with us
and looking forward to seeing some old
ones come back um
and you know as jeff mentioned this has
been uh
definitely a privilege to work on it's a
really fun game to work on
um and we really appreciate our fans and
uh
yeah looking forward to uh to steal rain
and we've got a lot of other cool things
like
the pit coming up in the future so we're
going to be busy
jeff gardner project lead and mark
tucker design director on fallout 76
thank y'all so much for sharing so many
details about the what's coming up in
the game and
i want to thank you all for watching as
well and i want you to stick to
gamespot.com because we have so much
more
for play for all with our charity
efforts our live streams and so much
more fun stuff in the world of video
games so
thank you all for watching and we'll see
you all next time
[Music]
you